i also just have to ask if you uh if you
ever encounter yourself
uh through memes and gifts
[Laughter]
you have become truly one of the great
gifts of the internet
and you laughing during your instagram
live with keely williams
uh has completely taken over the
internet what did you make of that
um you know she's like the meme of
corona
she literally is the kovid meme i was
spreading my peanut butter sandwich okay
i was just trying to eat my peanut
butter sandwich
and thoughts flew through my mind but
everybody has that moment and it's like
silence just brings a flood of [ __ ]
listen
i'm happy thank you very much for using
my meme where you know
where's my royalty if only we could
figure out a way to do that
right wow
okay can i just ask you you know doing
everything so publicly with keeley
was that planned was that therapeutic
for you i would never try to hurt you
like on purpose well i appreciate that
sweetheart and i
release any pain towards you that i have
and i cancel clear and delete it
we definitely talked about it there has
been such a buzz around cheetah girls
for a very long time and even more
actually we got a call from a mutual
friend i got a call from a friend of
mine and he
talked to everybody but her and um
trying to get the girls back together
anyhow
it was you know it was enlightening it
made me eat a peanut butter sandwich
or two orange three and we've got
miranda and raven
back on celebrity game face redemption
raven and miranda you guys look intense
like you're ready so okay
all right
what made you guys want to come back for
more well we lost
the first time and uh there was
i'm just gonna keep it real like there
was a week of just
can you believe that we lost can you
believe that we lost and
well she would wake up in the morning
and be like we're getting back on that
show we're gonna win again
i was like okay miranda i have to tell
you obviously i've been a fan of ravens
for decades and i am you know super
familiar with her brand and her sense of
humor but
really getting to know you and you have
also a pretty sharp tongue you had no
problem telling kevin hart a little quip
here and there
raven did that surprise you like oh no
i know exactly and you have to have that
kind of tongue if you're going to be
with me
because i need to be put in my place
here and there and you need to keep up
with me and she definitely
i'm following now which i like which is
not normal for me